so we have about 500 venomous snakes in
there serpent men are vital any of these
venomous snake could kill you
that's why we're working here we are
collecting Venom's to prevent them my
name is Aaron Gomez I'm the coordinator
of the second type this is a Central
America coral snake you get bit you can
stop bleeding and by this is a new
tropical rattlesnake
if bites you you can die after several
minutes so it is estimated that our
around 800,000 to 1 million people are
getting bitten by venomous snakes every
year we need the eyes next in order to
produce anti-venom there are no many
labs making that anti-venom
just like 6 we estimate to produce
around 100,000 miles per year so we
handle the snake we apply some massage
in them and the muscles of the head and
then we collect the venom in this kind
of special flask then we process the
venom we prescribe and then we collect
the venom in powder form and that value
is going to use to to produce the
anti-venom you get bit by a viper or
color sneaking in America or Central
America
lessen the chances that you're getting
on table and produced by Institute are
very very high this is terras yo pelo
and this one can kill you right drop
that kill most of the people use
fearlessness let's say there I'm not
afraid but I have respect off his leg
and you've never bet I never mean me
thank God
[Music]
you